>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: SINCE HER VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS OF MAINE
IS FACING FIERCE BACK LASH FROM
FEMINIST.
SOME OF THIS IS BEYOND MEAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MANY OF YOUR OPPONENTS ARE
GOING TO SAY SHE IS PRO-CHOICE.
SHE IS PRO-WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND
SHE JUST SENT A MAN ACCUSED OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT TO THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THAT'S POLITICAL COWARD ICE.
THAT'S SOMETHING WHO IS
PRETENTING TO BE A FEMINISM.
THAT'S FAKE.
>> A LOT OF WOMEN WILL FOCUS ON
SUSAN COLLINS.
HERE WAS A CHANCE FOR ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL WOMEN IN THE
COUNTRY.
SHE SAID I WILL TELL YOU AT 3
O'CLOCK.
SHE STUPID AS A WOMAN AND SAID I
BELIEVE THE GUY.
>> Sean: SCOTT MORRISON JOINING
US.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER-IN-LAW LAURA TRUMP IS
WITH US.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
IT SEEMS THAT THERE IS A HUGE
DOUBLE STANDARD.
HAVE YOU BEEN ATTACKED.
IVANKA HAS BEEN ATTACKED AND
MELANIA HAS BEEN ATTACKED AND
EVEN THE PRESIDENT'S SON WHO IS
12 HAS BEEN ATTACKED.
THEN YOU HAVE SARAH SANDERS AND
PAMELA ANDERSEN.
-- PAM BONDI AND PEOPLE
ASSAULTED IN RESTAURANTS.
THEN WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT SUSAN
COLLINS.
>> IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE A REAL WOMAN
AND REAL FEMMEISM.
LOOK AT SUSAN COLLINS.
SHE WENT AGAINST THE MOB COMING
AT HER.
EVERYONE TELLING HER, SHE SHOULD
NOT DO THIS FROM THE LEFT AND
FROM HOLLYWOOD.
SHE MADE A DECISION ON HER OWN.
THAT'S WHAT A REAL WOMAN IS
ABOUT TO ME.
I COMMEND HER.
KUDOS TO HER.
SHE DID THE RIGHT THING HERE.
AND YES, SHE SAT HERSELF UP AS
THE MOST POWERFUL SENATOR BY
MAKING EVERYBODY WAIT UNTIL 3
O'CLOCK.
THIS IS A SMART WOMAN AND THE
DEFINITION OF FEMINISM.
>> Sean: THE AMOUNT OF FEAR
MONGERING.
THERE HAVE BEEN CALLS, I HOPE
THE MOST VIOLENT ACT AGAINST A
WOMAN HAPPENS TO YOU.
THREATS TO HER OFFICE AND TO
HER.
I AM WATCHING THIS AND THINKING
THERE IS A GREAT HYPOCRISY.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE
GOING AFTER BRETT KAVANAUGH WERE
SILENT ABOUT BILL CLINTON,
SILENT ABOUT KEITH ELLISON.
WHAT ABOUT THE DOUBLE STANDARD?
>> THERE IS A COMPLETE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
IF YOU THINK THIS IS AS
RIDICULOUS AS THE REST OF US DO,
YOU HAVE THE CHOICE IN NOVEMBER
TO VOTE IN THE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS AND MAKE SURE YOU ARE
VOTING FOR TRUMP SUPPORTING
REPUBLICANS.
WE SEE HOW RIDICULOUS THE
DEMOCRATS CAN BE.
THEY KNOW NO LOWS.
THEY GO LOW AND WE GO HIGH, I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY BELIEVED
THAT.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN
NOVEMBER TO KEEP THE MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
EVERYONE CAN DO THAT VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU ARE HAPPY WITH THE
DIRECTION OF THIS COUNTRY UNDER
DONALD TRUMP, VOTE IN THE
MID-TERM.
OTHERWISE THESE PEOPLE OF TAKE
CONTROL OF THINGS.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THEIR AGENDA.
THE TAX CUTS, THEY WANT THE
CRUMBS BACK.
THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE ICE AND
WANT OPEN BORDERERS AND KEEP
OBAMACARE AND IMPEACH YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW?
>> AND THEY ARE RUNNING ON
SOCIALISM.
IT'S SCARY.
EVERYONE SHOULD UNDERSTAND IF
THE DEMOCRATS GET CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE, THEY WILL TRY
TO IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT AND
TRY TO GET RID OF BRETT
KAVANAUGH ON THE SUPREME COURT.
THEY WILL PUT A HALT TO
EVERYTHING GOOD WE HAVE SEEN
HAPPEN IN THE COUNTRY IN THE
YEAR AND A HALF DONALD TRUMP HAS
BEEN PRESIDENT.
EVERYBODY SHOULD TAKE THAT VERY,